native aldi gets the call in the series
opener 10-8 this year he's got a 3-5-8
era a string of now six straight no
decisions for the right-hander so here's
aaron judge
the pitch to judge is lined toward the
gap and right left center it's a base
head one hop off the left center field
wall lemay who scores
and
holding at third is rizzo
and so judge gets a big hit a line drive
double to the left center field wall in
the ribby and the yanks take a
one-nothing lead
so for stanton a ground ball to second
or short
means a run
and the pitch is grounded too short a
run scores good job stanton the throw to
first is in time from bogarts stanton
got the job done he made contact hit a
ground ball to short it's two nothing
yanks
and with two down here is glad torres
and there's a base hit the center field
judd scores it's another big hit for
gleber torres and the yankees lead three
nothing
and here's her shallows move to
shortstop he's hitting at 264 with 13
homers
the old one is swung on lined and nice
backhand stab made by iglesias in second
for the out wow that ball was scalded
yankees ace garrett cole gets the call
in this opener he takes them out at 15-8
with a 3.08 era rocked last time out
against the indians one on one out
and that will bring up xander bogarts
and he's at 304 23 homers 79 rbi's
and kohl's pitch is hit on the ground to
short feed second there's one on to
first it's a double play
and the inning is over so cole was given
three runs and he made it stand up no
runs no hits and no one left now at the
end of one ending to play three-nothing
yaks verdugo at 290 13 homeless 59 rbis
and the pitch is caught on him she threw
it by him at 100 i guess
upstairs 100 no two out and here's
hunter renfrow
and the pitch cut animus struck him out
swing
two strikeouts the inning for coal
no runs no hits one left
at the end of two three nothing
here's stanton first and second nobody
out
and the pitch is swung on hit in the air
to right and deep that ball is high it
is far it is gone
into the bullpens in right center field
he did drive the ball to right field and
he did drive it out a stantonian home
run
it is a three run blast giancarlo
a nocio stopolo
he drills a three run home run and the
yankees now take
a six-nothing lead in the third inning
in boston one is on first and second two
outs here's higashiyoka
and the pitch is popped up
right in the middle of the diamond is
going to catch it the first baseman that
drops how do y'all like that
i'm telling you you could see indecision
i could see indecision so gallo
scores so i mean it's already seven
nothing anthony rizzo's almost
legitimately literally trying to put
this game away
salomore throws and rizzo swings and
misses he struck him out well sawamura
in the final analysis although it was a
little hairy
made a couple really big pitches in that
inning however the yankees get four
across
and here is
the catcher christian vasquez to lead it
off now here's the two one
swung on and lined and made the grab by
glabor
labor little jump got the high line
drive
and that's the first out of the inning
and here is kyle schwarber now here
comes the 3-2
he struck him out swinging i was a
change the last thing i guess he thought
would be a change and he swung and
missed
so
for the red sox no runs no hits one left
and they're two down
for glebe torrence
torres an rbi single in the first inning
when they jumped native aldi for three
runs
[Music]
been caught by alexander
well here's the 2-2 to debra's
and the pitch cut out of miss blew him
away with a high fastball away fourth
strikeout for cole
and here is alex verdugo
here is the o2
and it's grounded right back to cole
knocks it down throws to first ends the
inning
so the play goes one three
no runs one hit one left
lemayo is single to right to open that
three run first brought it ashore and
walked
swinging the ground ball bounced to the
shortstop to his right bogarts has it
buyers have plenty of time to retire the
side
they don't score in the faf they leave a
runner at third after four and a half
seven nothing yankees they're a two way
and here is iglesias
red sox now the first wild card two
games ahead of the yankees who have the
second wild card and that's strike three
iglesias down looking to play gallow big
time to pull three and two stanton a
huge lead at second pitch there's a
fastball and what do you know called
strike three on the inside corner
he struck him out
barnes gets around the double
it's just the fifth fastball he threw of
22 pitches we go to the bottom of the
sixth
so here's and bogart's
the o2
strike three bogor is down looking
here's raffy oh for two he's grounded
third and struck out
1-0 to raffle the pitch swinging a high
drive down the right field line it is
way back and it is gone
[Applause]
rafi gets cole again
another three run homer
and it's 7-3 yankees
here is left-hander martine perez
and the first guy he will face is glaber
taurus
by ball center field and deep going back
hernandez he's going to turn and play it
off the wall
as gleber torres has himself but no he's
going for three
and he is going to make it
[Music]
no one was covering third base and
hernandez took his time getting the ball
in that looked like a homer to me they
got it they're going to check this that
ball went up in the stands that jumped
up there
so it's labor day
and like a good glaber torres is there
le mayhew in his career against martine
is seven for 18 with a home run runner
goes from second here's a high drive in
a deep left center field back into tk he
is back into the track in front of the
wall he's there to make the play
runners were 90 feet further ahead kiki
great running grab a deep deep fly ball
rizzo tonight single double twice struck
out it's crazy we're in the seventh
inning and this is the fifth at that
anthony rizzo 8-3 yankees and a
one-strike pitch from martine
throws him out
and bobby dalback will come in and pinch
it for schwarber
swinging and a miss
and that will bring up the top of the
order in kiki hernandez who the yankees
haven't retired tonight two walks and
two singles
and the pitches popped up
high in the air to right judge walks in
judges there he makes the catch ball
game over yankees win the
yankees
win
you